bust out the coloring books and
emergency therapy llamas Democrats are
having night terrors that a third party
bid will spoil Biden's re-election plans
Joe manchin given his biggest tease yet
that he might join a Unity ticket
we're here to make sure that American
people have an option and the option is
can you move the political parties off
their respective side they've gone too
far right and too far left if they have
another option then they're in trouble
both parties in trouble I've never been
any race I've ever stole I've been
racist to win and if I'm getting to
raise someone to win
that's exciting and if you listen
closely you can hear the sounds of
millions of Democrats screaming
it's maddening it would most likely hurt
President Joe Biden in its re-election
campaign but let's say for some reason
we see a moderate Republican when the
GOP nomination then it could potentially
hurt them that will be his legacy for
the rest of his life Joe manchin helped
elect a fascist they call themselves No
Labels honestly because like oligarchs
gentlemen's club was like you know too
much on the nose of a name for them is
that the only thing that Dr West's
candidacy can do is help elect Donald
Trump seem to be a a very Charming Man
and he's also a minister the threat of
the continued constitutional order in
the United States
so uh Harold it's a threat to democracy
our constitutional order by having
another candidate run for president
people just hate third party candidates
because the one closest to their
preferred candidate gets hurt whether
you're a Democrat or Republican
everybody feels the same way so when we
see a left Winger we go ha ha ha he's
gonna hurt Biden but you know that if
Trump doesn't get the nomination and he
becomes a third party candidate
Republicans are going to lose
I think you said it well in my I'm 53 in
my lifetime the most serious uh
independent candidacy and candidate was
Ross Perot in 92 and 96. uh his
candidacy by all uh analysis helped uh
president then Governor Clinton then
President Clinton get reelected uh RFK
No Labels Professor West have something
in common uh they're all thinking about
running because they don't like the lot
the potential or should say what is
perceived to be the likeliest lineup on
the Republican Democrat side of Biden
Trump rematch now listening to No Labels
and listening to my old friend Joe
manchin he has said that if he gets in
this race he's going to win the American
people don't want a third party
candidacy for the sake of vanity for the
sakes of of expressing a strong opinion
if you can't win I think that the
American people will reject it and
frankly I think the way you analyze this
correct that if it's president Trump who
runs his independent if it's no labels
of Professor West as I listened to
Professor Carville there uh or James
Carville there at the end there it will
it's easy to decide to determine who
will win the election if any of these
things happen so I uh I think everybody
should talk about running but if you're
serious about winning you've got to
think long and hard about whether you
should run this is why I have the
solution Jesse the solution is
I don't really have one no here it is
you have two third parties yeah so it's
kind of like if if there's a third party
that can hurt your side yep there's
another third party that can hit you
hurt yourself
so it'll be four parties but there's
really two major parties and two third
parties it's a lot of parties and no
one's having any fun and if that has a
problem then you have two more but you
can never have an odd number yeah then
we're like the Europeans yeah there's
like thousands of parties you could win
with like 10 that's the kind of
democracy I like winning with the
minority I was kidding we Donald Trump's
due for some luck though he was cruising
last time and covet hit so he could use
a spoiler it also would help so he could
pardon himself with the old pocket
pardon if he's inducted and convicted he
might have cut a deal with mansion he
might have said Joe you run third party
you spoil it for the incumbent Joe I get
back in the white house and then I tap
you for cabinet Secretary of Energy
Secretary of interior that way then you
can kind of ride out into the sunset
you're a hero in West Virginia and
you're also really rich
but it does feel like both parties are I
guess the Democrat called a bribe yeah
no that's called politics oh God that's
called a deal but it does seem like the
Democrats are running too hot and the
Republicans are running too cold the
Democrat Wing where it's like you got
prosecutors the media and the Intel guys
they're just bloodthirsty obsessed
trying to kill Trump that's all they
care about and the rest of their party
is like can we talk about a health care
education and wages over a year and then
there's the Republicans that have
totally lost any emotion the whole
country's engulfed in flames and they're
trying to maintain this air of
respectability you got boys in the
little girl's room you got you know the
former president about to get arrested
you know you got the open border you got
a high crime wave and they're sitting
there and they say nothing so there's
there's an eruption going on on both
sides because the people at the top
don't listen to the people at the bottom
what do you think of the No Labels
they've been around for like maybe 15
years and this I never really hear of
them you never hear from them and you
know what they said was if it's Trump
and Biden we may not support a candidate
a third-party candidate anyway so I'm
like why are we even talking about these
people but the craziest part of it is
historically third-party candidates have
always underperformed so initially
they'll come out and people will say oh
you know it's great they're independent
but when it gets to election they don't
do as well as they did before the
election but what I think is incredible
you had that person from MSNBC right we
want to keep the two-party system in the
United States because institutionally as
a country we need it all of a sudden the
left believes in institutions they want
to tear down the statues they want to
make sure that the Supreme Court goes so
they can all the institutions are bad
unless it preserves you know Joe Biden
and this the fear is that that
um they don't care about anything other
than destroying Trump and that Mansion
if he's in there he'll take votes away
from Biden that's the only thing that
they're worried about and in the end you
know Carvel is even going now saying
that this guy Cornell Wild is a threat
to the constitute Cornell West I'm sorry
is it threat to the Constitution he's
not a threat to the Constitution
everybody's a threat to democracy if you
don't go there ideological way and they
they don't want him to run and the truth
is you know uh they just want to bully a
third-party candidate let's assume that
there is one let democracy take its
course let it run its course stop trying
to bully people to support your side I
really wish it was Cornell Wilde yeah
that was a classic actor from the from
the old school of acting was he in the
most dangerous game is quite a quite a
man's man Kaylee is before your time
Cornell Cornell Wild he could win the
Gen zivo yeah there you go you know um
do you notice what they're doing to RFK
is exactly kind of what they do did to
Trump which is they par they parse every
one of his words it's like they don't
okay like anything he says somehow
undermines all of the Deeds he's done
yeah so it's like suddenly he's
anti-semitic but he has never never had
an anti-semitic deed in his life but
that's what this is what they did to
Trump oh it's the same Playbook
anti-Semitism racism you know misogyny
et cetera they do it's Trump they do it
to RFK anyone they don't like
um but there are three Joes in this race
there was the Joe and the oval who today
for about 10 seconds looked like he fell
asleep like his head was down he was
mumbling with the Israeli president
really peculiar then there's the Joe
that matters which is the Joe Mansion
because Joe manchin would Doom a Joe
Biden candidacy would absolutely Doom
him you look at the late breaking
members of third party voters two to one
uh they went for Joe Biden as compared
to Hillary Clinton so uh my point is
Third Party candidate could really mess
up and then you got the third Joe Joe
Exotic who's running for federal
penitentiary who has a better chance of
winning than Joe manchin who says if
Iran I'm going to win I hate the if I
run crap aren't you tired of the the
flirting and the teasing yeah you know
well I'm titillated but oh yeah
well it is it is content it is you know
it's summer we have to come up with
stories that's right all right ahead
they they tried locks and Plexiglas now
liberal cities are resorting to chaining
up your ice cream hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now